this is your man conceded and was crazy
as I became a meme by accident and this
is that story he and this story starts
to be back in December 2009 the average
a 2009 back then I was a battling heavy
so I was just writing rhymes everything
my sword shot any time I had back that
in going to the mall to shop back then I
was going to UM I was enough to develop
some water broke the storyline Hrothgar
and the rugby line so that was basically
my whole day today was writing battle
ball isn't gonna get some rugby year but
was driving me back then career I was
actually what what I was doing was
really just battle record that was
really all I wanted to do I didn't want
to be a studio rapper or musician
whatever it was just to battle be the
biggest battle oh and one of the biggest
bachelors the batter world is a missive
it's weird cause it's a very big but
very small world
I mean his big ahead and still use of
use online but all the people are
scattered all over the place and some
battle rap was taking off getting a
little more mainstream you know as I
would go to Times Square or go somewhere
here you know I mean we would get
noticed that was a big difference no I
was in Miami today I was on some fish
and I noticed I walked to the ball and
st. Louis and got notice how I mean I
was a big deal so it was definitely
happening at the time
yeah I mean I was a big battle rapper so
you know it was me and Hollerith on this
was the bar there the battle to sing
goes to a person set it up there's some
dudes I hit that that won the battles
this went smack some had their first
event in st. st. Louis my first time
going smacks first time boy it was a
dude named Jesse James never pay out of
his own pocket so we can bang that's the
way it's gonna have to go I was like I
need this amount of money flight hotel
of course like I cool we got all that
somebody I'm gonna
open cover so my job was to make sure
you never want to be seen and heard from
ever again
so that was my mentality was going into
the battle other than that my first time
in the in the in the moon and just see
was she was suddenly shot it
chinese-food their piece and it is today
I mean I was just ready and really comfy
because I'm like I knew it's nothing he
could do to the murder capital but don't
get too relaxed Norfolk as well food
wrappers this way so he was gonna get me
a nice wrapping and then he'll stay but
I don't need that strap to drag across
the second he touched that runway they
find his body pulling the front net
pizza book article so when he stumbled
face all right you about to kill
yourself and then when he got back on
track I like I hope you got it she got
it together nowadays the fans are a
little more lenient back then it was
more like you smoke especially never got
my damn life it just as if nothing new
it was like I'm another just another
person to put in the backyard and agree
that's it that's all my bad was even
from but I better than the jungle and
grind time I was I was always making
faces and it was usually just my facial
expressions for when I would say her
line I mean that I think we would get
from head I'll lean back let the crowd
go crazy
soon I would just always do facial with
the officials first it was never for
some bigger purpose it was just my
character I wouldn't do it purposely to
try to gain something cuz it's gonna
look forced and McCarney because if I
really put my focus into that I probably
started doing doing making a face that I
don't normally do it isn't like though
let's just keep doing so fast-forward to
like six seven years later you know I
mean now television oh my god I'm still
I was still bad a bit mean thumb thumb
that had dad the batter was like a 10
million views now television during the
whole while a mouthing reoccurring cast
cast number things
good and then start seeing the me come
up sporadic or I don't remember the
first time seeing it but it didn't
started gradually going and then one day
I don't know what happened it just X
below everybody is using ESPN they got
one where they put the face on Jesus and
it was like I'm single because God is
waiting for me to find to find that
special someone and it was God it just
was crazy like there was no limit to
where it would put it he just goes to
show that is so dope that something
organic changes happening real life
event and informed making me Monica that
members years even years later and you
revived it after all these is why what
but I mean I'm a dad I remember like it
was yesterday you do walk up to me you
know hey take a picture till I kill you
to uh you know get a mean guy right you
this time and I was like yeah yeah yeah
yeah turn my yellow yeah man though so
you took the picture at my man's in my
man's like yeah that's what you don't
run from you like yeah yeah sees me all
yeah all the time unless you know him
from like battle rat while and I was
like nah I'm out of watch battles that
around my belly watch TV oh my god this
year that actually just was coming to be
strictly for the mean only knew
absolutely nothing else but I just
thought about like damn is actually dope
that you know that people can send my
beam and attacks in this and bad so you
know that you know it didn't really I
didn't really take it in as far like you
know this is gonna be the new form of
communication even on the iPhone but you
can just send a check either typing
conceded that that pops up so I mean
it's just I think that's is I got
nominated for an award for though I'm
shorty awards and there was a news Ferb
I think best meme or something so I'm at
the table by the table you know with
other
shorty award nominees we're all talking
like yo oh yeah
what are you here for now my game man
for mean they're like mean they're like
holy wait it's this you everything girls
like
so you know now that I was going to do
my perspective has changed completely it
was a little different for me because I
already had you know some kind of
notoriety ready but you know I was
always thinking about the girl who was I
think the girl with the hand like this
the dude the dude on the phone with the
own glasses I always wondered like damn
I wonder what their life is like right
right right now the people prompted him
oh [ __ ] can I get a picture and they're
like why now if I was able to do it
again the actual act I would do
everything exactly the same but this
time after I would just capitalize on it
Weibo I would try to blow it up to
something way way way bigger to try to
hopefully get a digital cartoon series
maybe or something you know just
anything and way faster I train late
well day to day for me now is basically
basically still the same as before a lot
of places it's a lot or a lot a lot of
pictures but I'm still I'm still to say
on the video getting going shopping for
shoes and clothes daily and just you
know still I'm still writing raps still
writing jokes you know just everything
so I'm just still basically but just
basically the same just elevates a
little more so my advice for anybody who
gets caught up in this whole mean thing
and bam becomes one embrace it embrace
it go along with it so joke with it and
capitalize off it y'all can follow me my
handle with a conceited NYC and that's
all around that's my Twitter my facebook
on YouTube my Instagram everything
thumbr see y'all around on the Internet
hey peace I really mean it
[Music]